and jake paul
said i don't roll with tate i don't i'd
love to knock his ass out he said
something like that but then he said but
what i do support is
you know free speech but then his
brother said something else his brother
said
you know the [ __ ] that andrew tate says
will have a ripple effect much more
dangerous than you can imagine because
his narrative is truly hateful his
rhetoric has extreme negative energy in
it and it will affect impressionable
young people that won't show for years
from now and it's dangerous now this is
what he says logan paul you're saying
but but i want to say this before you
comment on it and then junior supported
you tucker supported you i think the
guys that like debate and
comedians people who appreciate humor
can understand that some of the stuff
you're saying is funny as hell you could
be a comedian if you wanted to but a
person has to really pay attention to
the comedy but you know some some can
run with it some cannot run with it when
you hear the people that support and
don't support you how do you process
that so first things first i want to
make it very very clear that logan paul
is absolutely not really a tool of the
matrix he's a bought and sold individual
with no soul he doesn't stand up for
anything and he doesn't mean anything he
says he gets pieces of paper from susan
or whoever else telling him what he's
allowed to say on his channel to retain
you believe that 100 non-do i believe
he's proved himself he will flip-flop on
any issue he can be bought and sold the
dude's a [ __ ] logan paul is a [ __ ] and
i will say that here publicly if anyone
wants i'll fight him for free the guy's
an idiot no money needed nobody goes to
paul logan paul doesn't believe in the
things he says logan paul is a man if
you ever were unfortunate enough to
consume his content i get sent clips of
it all the time by people mocking him as
soon as something comes out whether
terry styles wearing a dress whether
it's uh little nas twerking on the devil
whether it's this he just sits there and
goes yeah this is great yeah this is
great he is a talking piece he is the
mouthpiece for the agenda the people
have come along people who are trying to
force a narrative and they said look we
need to have some degree of control over
the exact demographic that tate has
control over we're going to use logan
paul and attempt to use him and he sits
there and just purports the [ __ ]
points of view that the whole hollywood
establishment want him to report he
doesn't believe in the things he said
he's told what to say and because he was
canceled before and it emotionally
destroyed him he sat on camera crying
his eyes out like a little girl instead
of being a man about it he is so fearful
of the mob and so scared of being
cancelled again that he's gonna sit
there and say anything he's told he
doesn't believe that [ __ ] before i was
canceled him and his boyfriend mike did
endless videos supporting me laughing
about me saying how funny i was tagging
me on instagram inviting me places etc
second i'm cancelled they flip reverse
it and [ __ ] themselves because they
don't want to get cancelled too they are
children that's all they are so logan
paul's a [ __ ] that's the first thing
about liverpool and what's actually been
interesting about this whole
cancellation thing is
it hasn't negatively affected me in any
serious way because i've been saying on
podcasts for years i know a cancellation
is coming i knew it was coming i knew
that as i got more popular and more
powerful to a degree that was going to
come but what it has done is it has
awoken the world to anyone who's
perspicacious enough to pay attention to
learn which individuals out here in the
social media space actually have
character and believe what they say and
which are completely bought and sold in
our tools to the matrix the people who
have decided to stand up for me and say
no this is [ __ ] are people who have
to some degree credibility you know this
is this is people who say what they
truly believe but the people who were
totally a fan
and then post cancellations [ __ ]
themselves in 180
and to get a new piece of paper to talk
from that should tell the public out
there exactly who's controlled and
whether these people have a genuine
narrative that they're trying to report
on the world and it's interesting
logan's one of them and there's a few
others but
i'm glad it happened just for that alone
because it's actually very clear if you
go to logan paul's last podcast where
he's discussing me all of his fans and i
will talk about fans and viewers in a
minute because i think they're very
different things all of his fans which
he has none of all of his viewers are
sitting there insulting him saying bro
they're your [ __ ] [ __ ] like everyone
all of his own watchers are calling him
names because it's so transparent and so
obvious what he's doing fans versus
viewers fan services very different
things so he doesn't have any fans he
has viewers and susan and the matrix and
the people in charge of social media
companies are like okay we've set our
media machine let me ask you guys
questions as professionals let's assume
as professionals let's assume what i'm
saying is correct let's assume that the
social media companies when they banned
me set their media machine to all
release thousands of news articles at
the same time trying to convince the
world i'm an evil man
if they had that degree of power and
influence which i think we can all
probably agree they do don't you think
they take their number one talking piece
to the demographic which is my fan and
give him a piece of paper and tell him
what to say
does that all make sense does that make
sense to say well we told all the news
to say tate's bad and all of his fans
are 18 to 25 year old men who do we have
on youtube who obeys us like a little
[ __ ] who who could speak to 18 25 year
old men logan paul okay logan here's
your piece of paper do you want to get
cancelled again logan no you don't get
cancelled do you no no you're saying a
call like that was me 100 the dude's a
[ __ ] he he one aid from a super fan
to just talking about my rhetoric being
dangerous
in 24 hours there's a difference between
you saying who you think he is
versus you making the speculation that
he got called by somebody to say here's
a narrative we want you to take or else
we'll silence you well logan is not
capable of independent thought so
someone didn't give him the narrative he
didn't think it up himself dude's an
empty vessel he says what he is told to
say somebody somewhere told logan what
to say and what stance to take we can
argue whether it was a social media
company whether it was his manager who
was fearful right whether whatever but
somebody sat with logan and said look
tate's getting a lot of smoke you were
cool with him your boyfriend mike was
cool with him he's getting a lot of
smoke right now you're gonna [ __ ] out
and he sat there and said yes sir yes i
will because he has no character or no
integrity if it was all the other way
around let's imagine he was getting
canceled and i truly believed it was
unfair i'd sit there on my own platform
and say this is [ __ ] because i'm not
bought soul known
he's an owned individual so he's always
going to say what he is told to say he's
always going to sit on podcasts speaking
to the youth promoting harry styles
wearing a dress saying that it's great
that little naz twerks on the devil in
real time for our children to digest and
then say i'm dangerous to the youth
because that's what he's been told to
say logan paul has absolutely no
capability for independent thought he
has no character as a man that's who
logan paul is if you enjoyed this video
and you want to watch the entire podcast
click over here and if you want to be
connected with experts influencers such
as kiyosaki tate connolly palmeteri
myself and others download the app
minect where you get a chance to connect
with these folks by the minute you get
to buy the minute or have face times
with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the admin act and start connecting with
influencers and experts today
[Music]